you
hey Ron I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen let's be honest with warm
weather in the forecast throwback
Thursday has become all about last
year's go steal barbecues and college
weekends yeah you can say we're pretty
excited oh I love day drinking and while
our first taste of summer might seem
like a good excuse to plow through a tea
cake we still have a full summer ahead
of short shorts bikinis and slinky
dresses to get her best to keep those
boozy calories in the chest so today I'm
going to show you my top tips for making
delicious locale cocktails as well as
three ears this tool recipes that'll
have you feeling great and having fun
all summer long first up my Pinot Grigio
melon ball spritzer spritzers are a
great way to stretch the flavor and
calories of your favorite white wine in
refreshing summer drink I start with my
go-to wine Francois salute and Pinot
Grigio from Argentina because it has a
big juicy fruit flavor a grapefruit and
pineapple and a lively finish it's
surprisingly a well-priced pick for
sipping with dinner or for casual day
drinking like what we're doing with this
cocktail first I use a melon baller to
cut out pieces of watermelon cantaloupe
and honeydew melon and freeze them on a
baking tray until solid once they're
frozen I mix three ounces of Francois
flirtin Pinot Grigio with an ounce of
sparkling water a dash of aromatic line
bitters a slice of lime and a few
flavorful melon balls to keep your drink
cool and add an extra burst of juicy
flavor garnish with a sprig of mint and
you're ready to party you can also let
your guests get in on the fun by setting
up a DIY spritzer bar here are some of
my favorites as well as some healthy
mindful drinking tips do use citrus
flavored or plain seltzer sparkling
water or club soda don't use tonic or
sweet pop do use fresh or frozen no
sugar added fruit herbs and citrus don't
use fruit mixes or purees that are
loaded with added sugar do pour your
drinks into taller glasses with lots of
ice don't pour your drinks into shorter
wider glasses without any ice research
shows that can actually trick your mind
into thinking you're drinking more
simply by switching up your glassware
and bulking up the portion of calorie
free ice do limit the boost in your
cocktail to
one and a half ounces of liquor or four
ounces of wine don't decide to whip up a
cocktail that involves the whole bar and
do have a sip of water between each sip
of alcohol and limit yourself to no more
than one boozy drink / lady and two
drinks per man each day next up my
watermelon mojito in a tall glass I
metal together the juice of one lime
with a small handful of mint and half a
teaspoon of sugar then I puree a cup and
a half of seedless watermelon with an
ounce of rum and a handful of ice
finally I pour the watermelon into the
mint and lime mixture and top it off
with an altitude of sparkling water and
finally my mango margarita with the
probiotic benefits of busy kombucha
first i puree a third of a cup of fresh
or frozen mango into a blender with a
teaspoon of honey a tablespoon of lime
juice and ounce of tequila and a handful
of ice finally transfer the whole thing
to a tall glass and top it off with
three ounces of mango kombucha so there
you have it three recipes and all the
tips you need to make sure you can have
your cake and drink it too without any
unnecessary guilt thanks so much for
watching more great summer entertaining
ideas be sure to subscribe to my channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen every week I power through five
long days of runs work emails errands
and chores and by the time Saturday
rolls around I'm comatose on the couch
in TV narath on mode no big deal until
the TV business turns a 12 full-blown
junkie snap binge sound familiar well
we're in this together this is my snack
confession here's all my top tips to
help you stop those mindless munchies